coming up on 6 26 on your monday morning  so before one of the aviators games last  week at the las vegas ballpark well i  got to be part of a global ceremony  involving a couple of local lions clubs  dozens of southern nevadans joined this  more than 100 year old service  organization thursday evening after i  read a proclamation from las vegas mayor  carolyn goodman as part of lions clubs  international's world wide induction day  and then and you are all welcome to sing  along as we play  america the beautiful  [Music]  beautiful evening out at the ballpark  and a shout out to all the lions for the  work they do in the community and for  inviting me to be part of this special  occasion a special shout out to esther  louis henry from the summerlin lions  club she was given the lions ambassador  of goodwill award one of only a dozen or  so such recognitions around the world  and congratulations to her